el tre
マルカツの店長金子智恵ですよろしくお願いします
[拍手]
私は6年ほど前から慣らしでドン活動を営んでいます
最初の3年派
おもちゃ毎月のような赤字でした
4度の倒産危機を訪れ
借金の総額は5,000万円まで膨れ上がっていました
お客様は少なくて売り上げや思うように上がらずしっかり果て
困り果て
精神的にいつもボロボロでした
一人でなんとかしようと
頑張って1日の睡眠時間23時間
という毎日でした
お店が終わってヘッド異動になって
車を運転して自宅に戻るなですが運転席で様力尽きて寝てしまい朝になってシャワーを
浴びて
音声に戻るっていう日々でした
今から思えば何を大切にして
室なければいけないのかという判断が間違っていたためお金の使い方時間の使い方など
いろいろなことを心配していたような気がします
本当に大切にすべきことはお客様に喜んでもらうということであり
喜んでもらうためにできることは料理を通じてだということをわかっていませんでした
しかし今では経営が
企業祈り本当にありがたいことに順調に売上を伸ばすことができています
この背景には品質向上への取組みやユニークなアイディアがあります
このプレゼンでは私がどのような取り組みをして経営を立て直し
そこから何をまだ中についてお話ししたいと思います
私がこうして原点に戻ってお客様の喜びを一番に考えようと思ったのですが何をして
いいか分からずとりあえずお客様に喜んでもらえるんだと思い
あるメニューの一室を向上させました
エビフライの指を大きくしたんです
しかも値段はそのままで
ですが自分から大きくなりましたよって言うな
なんか面白くないと思いました
そこで誰にも内緒でワンサイズ大きな海老を仕入れて
世界にお店で使ってみたんです
お客さんが喜んで下さるか楽しみで僕待っていました
ですが一週間たっても誰にも大きくなったとか
太くなったとか気づいてくれず
ふーんとちょっと少し
なりました
でもだんだん我慢できなくなった私はついにこんな作戦をとりました
声ですね
紙に印刷してプリントして背中にこうやってはったんです
そして
営業中にお客さんの前でずっと声で仕事をしました
初めは少し恥ずかしかったんですがでもお客さんが色金でくれるエーーーガーー
顔を見てどんどんどんどん僕も慣れてきたんです
はいはい
そしてそれはツイッターになったところ全国的に注目してくれました
お客さんからも何発展のとか声をかけてこっ声を掛けられたりもしました
話題になった池ぐらいを申し上げ度に言いました
こんな単純なアイディアで爆発的な効果があったんです
私はあまりにも
反響の大きさに期待付したほど大きくなかったと思われたくないため
もう1サイズだけ大きくしました
今ではそのレビュー雷を目当てに大勢のお客様がご来店されほどお客さんお店の名物の
ひとつになりました
背中に貼るなんてばかげ詰めている2ケルっている
味が心配になるダウトを超えることもなくむしろそこまでアピールするなら食べてみ
たいといって頂けるお客さまがほとんどでした
八かでアピールする店長可愛いと言われてちょっとだけうれしかったです
まあそうこうしているうちに
兄は少しずつ3型仮になっていきました
しかし今年の
今年になってコロナが世界中をせました
私のお店では
感染対策として
昨年の3月末にお持ち帰り専門英語に切り替えました
正直不安はありましたここまで行っ東本客さんが増えてきたのに
お客さんが減ってしまうのではないかと
スタッフの仕事も減りお給料も減ります
なんとか売り上げを確保するためにまず
印刷した持ち帰りメニューをできるだけ多くのお客様に
配りたいということが大切だと考えました
また一度お持ち帰りを5両講座くださったお客様にはレジで割引券
コロッケの匹会計などを渡して再び利用していただきたいと思いました
そうするとレジでお客様にお渡しするどうしても犬が増えてしまいます
そこでお持ち帰り専門営業のご利用お願いするお手紙お持ち帰りメニュー割引券
コロッケの引き換えけ
などひとまとめにして封筒に入れて渡ししようと考えました
でもここで思いました
せっかくだから何か印象に残るようなことちょっと笑えるようなものにしたいと
そして思いついたがこれです
ワイルドです
hey
はいろーって書いた封筒を作ったんです
お客様に我を渡して
買収したんです
その結果レジでスタッフから伊佐したいた場合の動員させた封筒を受け取ってお客さん
がほとんど笑顔になってくださいました
6がスタッフに店長からの賄賂ですって言って渡してくださいとお願いしたんです
お客様が人生で初めて賄賂を受け取ったとか
店長主も悪よのうとか乗ってくださったりとか
とてもお客さんが喜んで答えでございました
そのこともまたまた twitter とか
ネット番組とかネットニュースとかでね話題になって取り上げていただき私もはいる星
買収されたいと新たなお客様も増えました
おそらく電話になって goku たぶん日本で一番はいるを張ったと思います
はいるなんて卑怯だこんな試合にふざけるな
とお叱りを受ける形を不安もありましたがそんなことは全くありませんでした
次に僕がお持ち帰り専門映画認めこんなことも起きました
お店でいつも使っているお弁当容器なんですが2は透明で興味を使っています
中身が見やすいからです
しかしコーナーの4行行き影響でどうしても
透明な蓋が仕入れることができませんでした
黒2しか入らなかったんです
そこで私はせっかく中身が見えないならと
逆手にとってこんなお弁当を作りました
はい中身に何が入っていいか分からない謎弁当です
舞台に謎ベントっていうシールを貼って
えっと使いました
かなりゴージャスなお得なお弁当なんですが同4月が入っているか
エビフライが入っているかカラーが入っているか
お客様に分かりません
それでも良ければとご注文くださいとお断りした上で販売したところ本当に大勢のくる
さんがご注文くださいました
今まで食べたお弁当で一番若くした蓋開けるがドキドキする
想像以上にボリュームがあったあってびっくりした後ツイッターでも話題にして
いただきました
中身が分からないなんて不信不安で買えないとか
付箋紙っ不親切だとかなぁとお叱りを受けることはまったくなかったんです
エビフライの砂この貼り紙は色
謎弁当
いずれも多くの人に受け入れていただいたこれらの企画ですが
私が世間の人の人々を信じて何でもやってみよう
ちょっと変わったことをやって切ってを蹴られていられるとか思うようになったのは
これから
を愛する2つので行くことがあったからです
2018年2月
福井県をはじめ北陸地方が
大雪の被害に遭いました
スーパーやコンビニから宿老火が消え交通も遊んだされて
何千な兄もの人が多い機の中で閉じ込められたてまでは車から出られなくなりました
私はネットニュースでそのことを知ってどんだけ心細いかと心配になりました
そしてとりあえず少しでも行け続けられたと思ってこんなことを津田きました
父兄の皆さん
豪雪大変だと思いますがどうかご無事で
雪が明けてならに来ることがあったら風景見てわかるものをご提示で全部には半額にし
ます
こうつぶやいたんです
このツイートが瞬く間に広がりました
福井から石川富山新潟8
割引範囲を広げたこともあり5月末までのに
260名の方が食事に来られました
わざわざおりを言うためにと交通費も時間もかかるにも関わらず
私の半額にするというメッセージに応えようと努力からご来店されました
ちょっとした気持ちでも大勢の人にも伝わるものだと知り
私自身が本当に温かい気持ちになり
がんばれ器が鳴りました
北陸のしてだけずるいなら景ミニも半額にしろ
なあという批判は私が知る限り一つもなかったんです
自分が良いと思ったことをやってもいいのかもしれない
という自信のようなものが少し出てきました
そんな不陸からのお客様も少し落ち着き始めたころ私思い立ってあるポスターをお店の
外の壁に貼りました
それはこんなポスターです
まるかつ無料食堂のお知らせ
もしどうしてもお腹がすいて
家にお金がないときやお子さんにおいしいものをお腹いっぱい食べさせてあげたいのに
子治療があって難しい時などはこそっと店長に相談してください
電話がいいと思います
その時は店長のおごりでこそっと無料でお腹いっぱい食べてもらいます
を無視データというのが期末ければお弁当の持ち替えても大丈夫です
世の中がお互い様で獅子お題は出世払いでもいいです
はせてもらっても結構です少しでもで元気を出すきっかけになればうれしいです
ちょっとでも人様のお役にたてるという気持ちだけで十分嬉しいので本当に金銭等て
くださいね
際に僕はを
他に払ってくださっているお客様が不快に思えたり
豪快になったりしないかと心配になったためこんな文章も付け加えました
マルカツのお客様へ
いつも本当にありがとうございます
皆様に支えていただいているおかげさんでこういうアホなことができます
心配させてすいませんがご理解をよろしくお願いします
不快に感じられましたらお呼びしますすいません
貧困家庭の問題や子供虐待などの問題を報道で知って一言ではないと思いました
私にも何かできることではないかと考えてそんなに対しことができなくても食事ぐらい
は提供できるんじゃないかと思いました
僕は飲食店などでも食べてもらうことが何もできないのでこういうことしか思いつか
なかったんです
まだまだお店な兄は不安でしたが不安定ですが
私苦しんでいる人に少しでも助けになりたいと思いました
そしてをそろそろポッドポスターを張ってツイッターでつぶやきました
その結果
瞬く間に多くの下に入っ拡散していただき実際に無料色でを利用される方も現れ始め
この3年で利用された方は延べ600名ほどになりました
実際に利用された方
子供さんの大きな映画を見て無料色で始めたことがたとえ間違いであったとしても
きっと意味があると考えることができるようになりました
子どもたちに
面白いものを食べさせてあげられるような年ぶりですとおっしゃった言葉が僕に今でも
忘れられません
厨房で毎日料理を作り続ける意味にも改めて気づかされました
無料色でを始めたころは目や頭としているだけだ
売名行為だという批判もありましたがまぁではそういったやん的な意見はほとんどあり
ません
むしろその逆で他にはやってを食べてお召し応援したい
全国から本当に大勢のお客様来てくださるようになりました
このような取り組みを応援してくださる皆さんのおかげで僕は今でもお店を続けること
ができると思っています
税は何でも自分しておけ
頑張ろうとしていましたが
身も心も経営状態もボロボロになることでようやく自分の限界編を感じ自分の実力の無
さ
空を認めて自分のやり方にこだわる悩めよ
もっと勉強していろんなすん力を借りを
としてから店の経営は
上手くなったと思います
そう考えることで逆にちょっと変わった急いでいて皆さん力を貸していてくださるよう
なアイディアも出てくるようになってきました
そしてアイディアを実行しても行うことはありませんでした
エベラールをしなやかな貼り紙でアピールしても
ファイルをみんなにたくさん配っても
中目側からのおべんとを打っても
北リップの人だけ半額で料理を提供しても
他には払ってくださるお客様がいるように困っている誰かに無料で提供しても
怒られることはほとんどありませんでした
世の中湯がいて怒られないもんです
そして新しいことをやろうとしても多くの人が応援してくれよぉと力を貸して下さい
ます
なぜ私の取組が行わなかったのか理由を考えていました
それは
飲食店として正しいこと
お客様に喜んでもらえること
誰かを傷つけないこと
誤解を避けるために出来るだけ丁寧な言葉で説明すること
っていうことを4つを満たしていただかれたと思います
もちろん変わったことをやるには不安になることもあります
ですが飲食店としてきちんとしてお客様に喜んでもらえることを
誰かを傷つけないこと
下手くそでも言葉で説明することをやり続ければ
そんなに批判されたり怒られたりしないということを私に学んだつもりです
これが私のを無視が倒産寸前から復活できた秘密です
そしてこの4つのことは一色でのみならず他の分野で頑張るケースでも応用できると
思います
私はこの4つのことを守ることで自信が生まれ
人の鍵が必要以上に気にならなくなった
できました
これからも私は私なりに新しいことにチャレンジしていきたいとおもいます
このプレゼンでお伝えした私の学びが少しでも
これからあなたにとってお役にたてればこれほど嬉しいことはありません
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]